yeah anyone welcome to this video
playing w im2 Martella the name in there
Algy where and we end this consider
never heard never heard of her okay so
what is he doing what is she doing I'm
sorry okay see if someone who plays it
correctly for black here yeah that's the
main line not sure about the move water
myself sometimes okay so before
sometimes you can even play it
immediately and then go queen bee three
not quite sure this is such a position
that it could be right
take States will be 396 queen bee 7 look
fp8 and my queen the straps that's not
nice okay so let's go to be too then and
then play for before and there ok
interesting probably I let's let her
just take yeah look it's not so bad on
f2 in case of f4 f5 I will take and go
fo anyway
ok so night to III or what is going on
here can also push
[Music]
ok I want to do something here not sit
around I'm not sure yet does this might
be the critical moon cakes Bishop a6 was
one idea tix takes b5 this night before
that probably doesn't do all that much
yeah but the details if I she almost has
to do it what else is there something
extraordinary deet deet xe5 Bishop a6c
takes before I was thinking that this
this would be the continuation okay so I
cannot take i guess i mean it's not
terrible for white hood this is the most
direct way of doing it so she takes
before I must be the critical move and
yeah now all kinds of things are hanging
but this is always a tempo I mean this
is the most interesting movie I think
and take on c7 let's see
I and then have g6 and potentially 95-94
play in the center ok so i have to take
I don't have to take I can take on a
seven on c7 island I mean it's better in
terms of porn structure so maybe yeah
yeah nights you for it what is wrong
with that or why I actually I can take
the contiki five and disposition I guess
d 695
check out 9 f 1 let's save
you
take the Queen first and then that 95
there was the check and all kind all
kinds of chicks this now s-97 calling it
should be game over relay Queen a to
look see to it should work just to jacks
and I'm threatening 97 check and made
black design okay so let's have a look
them I'm so pretty new to this opening
so many things are not totally clear to
me so this was played and it couldn't be
true for before I looked logical to J in
general black is not so unhappy about
trading the bishop I mean the bishop is
not if you look at this pawn structure
not great on g7 but one thing is also on
part of this any f5 now has to be
considered very carefully for black
because if i take it and go away for the
whole king position opens up and there
is no bishop to protect you so it's
generally very complicated he played
this might be form and now we all see if
I looked like the way to go to me if you
do something slow it doesn't feel right
so c5 but this must be critical I mean
this is wrong I think because of b5 you
know the engine agrees this must be
wrong at black's pieces here completely
dis disarrange there i was thinking
night c4 actually in this position here
in the engine comes to this as well and
the idea now as d6 b6 those kind of
things and the night is of course
fantastically placed there in this is
terrible the engine inhale different
with d6 night a4 I have a g6 a
serological
open this up oops of course not this one
yeah I want those they took their that's
stronger she took the am sorry so we
should base six cakes yeah and now here
around here there must be the critical
moments I played nine to five so look a
six and here there was something okay
Queen to e7 aha so I'm not getting these
six and that's the problem hmm ok so
that was the big issue here with my
plane yeah yeah I don't get these six if
I get the six and that's great but I
don't get it like here I asuka see a map
and that's the big counterclaim hmm so
that had a big problem means I had to
take your first and then this what is
the difference I can take here I it's
still not great so that means night the
54 small ok computer wants to take them
well that makes it quite some sense here
this cannot be a bad thing exes me that
it's enough for black yeah maybe it was
equal them possible ok and after that
was mr. felt pretty good about it 25 I
was finest missing things left and right
there after Quincy five I had don't have
these eggs no I should have played it
immediately Wow only now I'm final yeah
note that this wasn't good check check
check
I didn't even see the maid but technique
there is one and now even Queen g5 still
hanging on only now it's lost with the
Queen hanging anthem 97 check and then
Queen h8 whoa tough game and a bit of
the lucky one thanks for watching